hallo YouTube cheslav us my friends this
is grunge in here welcome to the second
episode of sidelines against the move
Knight to c6 and in this lecture I'm
going to cover the move Knight to c3
which is a developing flexible and the
same tank very cunning move the White's
idea is to depending on the black
responses he can throw his own surprises
where black may or may not be
comfortable
well against this more I'm proposing the
equal flexible and developing move that
is Knight to f6 and white has few
choices amongst them if your opponent
plays the move Bishop to c4 or Bishop to
b5 then there will be a transposition of
my last lecture where I recommend that
you play the movie 6 and get a good game
out of it so other three moves needs to
be considered the first move I want to
highlight is the move f4 which is a case
of many Vienna opening player game but
especially against this black setup this
opening is harmless in fact it is black
who is in the driver's seat the move I'm
going to propose over here is the MU D 5
now I have done a lot of research
against the Moon Knight to c3 and the
nice thing against all this setup that
is either Knight to f3 f4 or d4 I am
proposing you play the move d5 so that
way the lot of theory is cut down and it
will be very easy for you to remember
this stuff so f4 defy and now if you
open and place the MU D 3 then there
will be some captures on e4 and at the
end black exchange the white queen not
only equalizing and miss placing the
white king but black has a very good
winning chances in one blitz game my
opponent try the move Queen to f3 which
at first sight looks very aggressive but
this is a rather dubious move and the
simple refutation is you play the
moonlight
d4 so hitting two sports and practically
white has the only response left that is
Queen to d3 afterwards D captures efore
Knight captures efore Bishop to a5 not
only pressurizing that night but there
is a long-term problem on the c2 square
after a long thinking my opponent come
up with the only move that is c3 but the
following sequence that is Bishop
captures Queen captures Queen captures
pawn captures and castle on the Queen
side black is far ahead in the
development and that d4 pawn is a goner
so we can straightaway dismiss this
Queen f3 nonsense the good thing about
this move defies its force white to do
something about this efore square now
the most general responses are either to
play the move ECAP is d4 or pushing by
so let's see them if ecaps is defy then
I propose here a very amazing line which
not only create threats with every move
but even after the base play by white
black obtain a decent advantage so here
I propose that you play the move Knight
captures d5 two responses has been try
the first response I want to cover is
the mood d 4 which is defending
therefore square well here I propose
that you play the move Bishop to fr and
created another threat let's say your
opponent is not careful and he
carelessly play a nature looking move
that is nightwear 3 this is disaster
because after simple move Knight d2 B
Phi how the hell white is going to
defend that c2 square
well the only logical reply looks like
Bishop to d3 but after Bishop captures
pawn captures and nightcaps is d4 do we
need to go further I don't think so yep
you got it so that was about Knight to
f3 blunder at this point if you open and
capture this Knight then it only help
blacks to develop his queen and then
castle on the Queen side so that is not
good either for the white so what word
should do
of course he has to defend this threat
so he has to play the move a three we
are going to create the third threat
which is after capturing this night we
play the move Queen to defy not only
stopping that Bishop to develop but
black is aiming to castle on the Queen
side and there is a nasty move is
waiting to be hit white plays this
careless move once again that is Knight
to f3 and black is winning how let's see
this
Queenie form check and no matter how
wide response for example Bishop to e2
then after Queen cap to c2 Queen
captures and Bishop captures in the
opening black emerge with a clear pond
advantage so that means Knight to f3 is
not possible so the only accurate
defense over here Bishop to e3
yep stopping that check but no matter
I'll show you a very clear-cut plan you
need to play the move Queen to e4 e 6
Bishop to d6 and then depending on the
white set up you can Castle I the longer
the shot so let's see a sample game in
this game I responded with the move e 6
well I can play Queen eat 4 but I just
prefer e6 at this point my opponent
responded here with the move Knight to
f3 I played as usual Queen to e4
attacking see - when III Bishop the only
logical replies Queen to d3 and after
this I played the move Bishop to d6 here
I thought that this Queen is strongly
placed so he wants to get rid of that
Queen so he played the move Queen
captures e4 and after I played Bishop
captures efore y can try to defend the
c2 square with 2 moves either keying to
d2 or Bishop to d3 well doesn't matter
to us because let's say in this game
white plays the move Bishop to d3 now
the plan is revealed whenever you get
this sort of position please remember
you have to capture this Knight and
seize your bishop pair main reason is
when white we capture yes material is
balanced but white position is almost
lost the
simple plan I'm recommending over here
is to play the move Knight to e7 g6 and
castle on the queenside and then start
pressurizing this isolated pawns I want
a very quick game in this line let me
show you that so here I continue with
the move Knight to e7 my opponent
responded with the MU c4 I played the
move castle on the Queen side and I
think he miscalculated over here he
thought that after the move CFI he's
strapping that Bishop but after just one
move there is a knight to defy it is
actually black who is winning so there
are two spots where black pieces are
attacking white response is pretty much
force white has to capture this Bishop
after high recapture he plays the MU D
cap to c7 I capture the d4 pawn and we
should just stop over here black has
this wonderful light very active rooks
and look at white crippled pawns
undeveloped ace what else you hope for
the advantage so that was about the
Moody for at this Junction white can
also capture this Knight so Knight
captures defy afterwards I can
definitely capture with the Queen and
now our queen is very ideally placed
because there is no Knight to c3 move to
harass our queen
the usual line continues with the move
Knight to f3 Bishop to g4 Bishop to e2
and here I'm recommending a very strong
move that is the MU ePHI conforming
black advantage now I reach this
position many times in my games and I
like cover few interesting replies by
the white over here now most popular is
castle but let's see how the Moose first
I want to cover the mo s3 which looks
like a decent move but here the good
reply is to play the move capturing the
night and after Bishop recaptured black
and played the movie for so more or less
force the bishop to go back to the e2
and now black responds is with the move
Bishop to c5
so not only stopping why to castle on
the Kings side but black has this
wonderful pawn on e4 which create a
cramping effect on the white camp
you can either castle short or the long
so this is a very good position for the
black now the second move I tried over
here is the immediate c4 so attacking
the Queen well here I propose you play
the move Queen to e4 and invite him to
do his worst by playing the move d3
because after the d3 it is black who has
the attacking position the game
continues with the move Bishop to b4
check and now White has to move his king
the simple reason is if white plays the
move Bishop to d2 at this point then
after Bishop captures Queen captures and
Queen captures f4 why it is lost the
opening battle so that means white has
to play the move King to have fun here I
continue with the move Queen to g6 he
played the move F captures ePHI which I
personally think is a mistake because of
blacks next mu that is castle on the
Queen side he played the moonlight to h4
which more or less give the winning
position for the black so there are some
force replies that is Bishop captures
Queen captures Queen captures Queen
captures and rook captures yes material
is balanced but look at the pathetic
development of the white piece and look
at the tremendous activity of black
pieces not to mention this week pawns
so that was about c4 White has also
tried this move that is Knight captures
ePHI we are black and easily continue
with the move Knight captures ePHI and
however wide reply is getting a lost
position for example if Bishop captures
g4 then the simple replies Queen
captures g2 hitting two soft spot if F
captures ePHI then the simplest is Queen
captures g2 and after rook to a fun
yup it's Bishop to e7 and then it has to
start doing King dance now let's look at
the word of you smooth that is castle at
this point black should play the movie
for hitting the night and after Knight
to e5 once again we can capture this
night again White has two choices over
here the main moves Bishop captures e4
but let's see other moves for example if
might capture this Knight then we can
continue with the move Bishop to c5
check King to h1 Bishop captures e to
Queen captures e 2 and then castle on
the King side to illustrate the danger
in this position I like to show you once
again my own game where my opponent
instead of developing his Queen side
piece he tried to grab for the pawn with
the move rook to f4 which actually cost
in the game here I played a very cunning
move that is rook to b8 and then when he
captured my e4 pawn black has this
amazing shot that is a 5 so more or less
trapping the rook and if the rope moved
then the e5 pawn drop he come out with
only continuation that is Queen to c4
but after Queen captures rook captures
and rook to e5 not only saving my piece
but there is a backlink made thread is
also exist so at this point where has to
capture the bishop well here the line
continues with the move Knight captures
and after Queen captures we'll play the
move f5 so bolstering our pole and same
time hitting the Queen white plays the
move Queen to e2 now we play the move
Bishop to c5 check and after King to h1
we can simply castlelong yes in terms of
material position is balanced but in
terms of development you can already see
the difference the most critical try is
capturing the a pawn with the F pawn but
I don't think so this will help fight
from getting out of the trouble against
this I'm proposing that black should
capture the e5 pawn so pressurizing the
f3
squared tremendously so that's more or
less force right to play nightcap see
fire Queen captures nine so pinning the
bishop so white cannot castle
my opponent responded here with the move
deform
I stuck my queen on the e-file with the
move Queen to b6 he played the move s3
I played Bishop to h5 he played the
Mooji fine so finally getting out of the
pain but after Bishop to g6
fish up to f4 Bishop to d6 he plays
Queen d2 so trying to castle on the
Queen side but after my next move that
his sketches captures castle on the
Queen side white to his horror find out
that his King is going to stuck in the
center for a long time so a sample line
can run like this so here my opponent
continued with the move c3 I continue
with the move rook h2 eh and I think
black who is getting all the fun then
white is going to defend all the time so
those are some of the wonderful lines
it's time to move on and have a look
what will happen after the move e5
after the movie fire I'm going to
propose a very forcing sequence which
more or less give black a slight
advantage the move on proposing is to
play the move d4 so counter attacking
the white knight and if the knight moves
for example Knight c2e2 then black can
occupy this wonderful spot that is a
Knight to d5 so this is already a great
advantage for the black so that means
white cannot give up the ground so why
it has to go for this complication that
is e captures f6d capture c3 and now
half captures g7 here I propose that you
should capture this D pawn and now there
are two ways white can respond over here
if you opponent capture with the Queen
then I propose that you capture the
Queen
then take on g7 so hitting the p2 square
the most obvious response is to castle
on the Queen side afterwards we are
going to play the move Bishop to g4
hitting the rook if Knight f3 then the
pawn will be double so the most obvious
response is Bishop to e2 afterwards we
play the move H Phi to understand the
plan of the black campaign I like to
show you one of my own game where my
opponent responded here with the move
Knight to f3
I played castle on the Queen side and
now he played the move h3 so he just
want to have the bishop pair well it
looks good but actually it's a mistake
here I capture this night and after
Bishop recapture I played the obvious
move that is Knight to d4 so that Bishop
is going nowhere so it's it's ok they're
white captured black's bishop but now
black is going to capture white bishop
my opponent is pointed here with the
Mook to have fun but after the simple
continuation that is night captions rook
captures and the positional move h4 why
it has a big big problem you can see I
have highlighted over here this one pawn
is covering these two pawns that means
this b2 point will remain backwards and
that means black can easily play the
move Bishop to web 6 and double his rook
on this B file pressurizing this and
having all the fun well on the
counterpart why doesn't have any
counters left so this is more enjoyable
position for black after the move C
captures d2 I can also capture with the
bishop which is one of the main line but
here black can continue with the move
Bishop captures g7 so hitting the b2
square once again and this time around
why doesn't have the move castle so he
has to meekly defend with this move
c3 now to show the plan of campaigns I
have two games for you the easiest plan
you want to adapt over here is to play
the move Bishop to e6 and after the
usual developing move let's say Knight
to f3 black wants to continue with the
move into d6 so idea is very simple
black wants to castle on the Queen side
as soon as
possible and then start attacking why
either on the kingside or in the center
now the most usual response over here
from the white is to double the Queen
and Bishop battery on a and D fun so let
me give you a sample line here my
opponent continued with the move Queen
to e4 check so his idea is also to
protect the a2 pawn and castle on the
Queen side I just castle on the Queen
side and now White has two choices if
white plays over here Bishop to b5 then
I propose that you play the move fish up
to defy the usual line continues with
the MU castle on the Queen side
afterwards you clarify the situation
with the movie six in one blitz game my
opponent replied over here with the move
Bishop to c4 completely overlooking
blacks next move I wonder if you can
spot it
the amazing move Knight to b4 after a
few calculation my opponent captured my
bishop and I capture with my knight he
played the move Bishop to e3 which it
first line looks very obvious because
it's spinning my knight but after my
next move that is Queen to g6 the bishop
himself found in a trouble so he did
route back to the detune after a few
calculation I grabbed the g2 pawn which
is normally very risky but in such a
position it's a quite safe because what
has a piece hanging on f3 so my opponent
thought that is a big mistake because he
played the move Knight to g5 hitting my
f7 in the same time there is a threat of
rook to g1 but I parry from all this
threat with a very tricky move might be
six hitting his queen he played the move
Queen to b3 attacking my f7 and now
comes the super shock can you see it yep
it's row captures d2 and fight has to
resign so that was about Bishop to b4
the usual response is castle on the
queenside at this point and here I
propose that you should play the move
Queen to defy attacking a two so that
force white King to move to the b1 and
now you play the Mook to d6 so idea is
to triple on the D file and create some
counters on the D file now two moves has
been try against me in the first game my
opponent try the move c4 I responded
very energetically I played Bishop to a5
check and after King to a1 I played the
move Queen to b4 he responded with the
mu a3 so he just want to avoid some back
length tricks but after blacks next move
that is look to the H I created some
concrete thread my thread is very simple
I want to sack my double rook on the d2
and then checkmate white on the b1 why
thought that this is not a good attack
can he come out with the move Knight to
g5 so hitting my queen now I'll give you
a few seconds over here
can you find a mortar which will give
you a winning edge I hope you find this
more that is rook captures d2 BAM why
doesn't have any much of the choice why
it has to accept this Queen sacrifice
but after this black will continue with
the rook captures with a check and after
King to h2 now comes Bishop captures e4
no wonder the game doesn't last long the
second move White has tried is Knight to
g5 but this is already outright mistake
the simple refutation is you play the
move Bishop to g4 hitting the route and
if the rook moves then the bishop drops
my opponent's idea was to play the move
Bishop to c4 so hitting my queen and
same time supporting the rook but after
the following sequence that is Bishop
captures rook Bishop captures Queen
Bishop captures Queen and the move c4
after a few complications that is I
played the mu e six hitting his Bishop
he captured my f7 pawn and now I capture
his Bishop he captured my rook I
recapture his Knight and after the movie
three pawn captures pawn captures and
the moves c3 it is only black who has
the last laugh well that is pretty much
you need to know to play confidently
against the MU f4 and I hope with this
wonderful analysis you can get the
initiative start from the opening it's
time to move on and look at the other
move that is Knight to f3